it's possible they take two giant
magnets and use the repulsion force
between the two to lift objects into
space or can we set up stages along the
way up and have that attraction and
repulsion force send a type of space
elevator up to the moon or anywhere we
want to go let me know what you think
Nick Nick Nick this is an interesting
question let me say though starting out
we all when you play with magnets and
you feel the repulsive force that seems
strong but notice that it acts over a
very short distance it just nominally it
goes it's not perfect but you can
estimate it by saying it goes off as the
cube of the distance so if you get if
you have magnets this far apart and you
make them twice that far apart they only
have an eighth as much Oh so getting
using a magnet to push things up as high
as the atmosphere would take an enormous
ly strong magnet and where would that
energy come from and to give you an idea
of the kind of energy we're talking
about the particle collider in
Switzerland which we call CERN the
Center for Nuclear Research but in
French the adjectives at the end that
takes the electricity of a small city to
keep protons going in a circle just just
protons so just imagine how much
magnetism you would need to push
something of reasonable mass up into the
sky it would take a huge amount of
energy so shooting from the hip I'd say
it's really not possible with that set I
like the way you think then you also
referred to using stages to get the
magnet this magnetic car or craft pushed
up keep in mind that whatever you push
it up from has to be pushed from a place
which is somehow anchored to the earth
or magnetically repulsed from the earth
so it becomes very difficult practically
to have a stack of magnets that's stable
that has all that electricity or all
that energy required to create that much
man
probably you probably couldn't do it but
that's very creative that was cool
carry on Nick